WORLD.
I'M WOLF BLITZER.
YOU'RE IN "THE SITUATION ROOM."
WE BEGIN THIS HOUR IN UKRAINE
AFTER ONE OF THE BIGGEST RUSSIAN
MISSILE ASSAULTS SINCE THE START
OF THE RUSSIAN INVASION.
LET'S GO STRAIGHT TO THE
CAPITAL, KYIV.
OUR SENIOR INTERNATIONAL
CORRESPONDENT BEN WEDEMAN IS ON
THE GROUND FOR US.
BEN, SO WHAT ARE YOU SEEING AND
HEARING OVER THERE?
>> Reporter: WELL, WHAT WE HEARD
AT ABOUT 9:00 THIS MORNING LOCAL
TIME, WOLF, WAS SEVERAL LOUD
EXPLOSIONS.
ACCORDING TO THE MAYOR OF KYIV,
16 RUSSIAN MISSILES WERE FIRED
AT THE CAPITAL.
THEY WERE ALL INTERCEPTED BUT IN
SOME CASES THE INTERCEPTIONS LED
TO DEBRIS FALLING TO THE GROUND.
P WE WENT TO TWO SEPARATE
RESIDENTIAL AREAS WHERE HOMES
WERE DESTROYED, PEOPLE WERE
INJURED.
THIS IS WHAT SOME OF THE
RESIDENTS IN THOSE AREAS TOLD
US.
[ SPEAKING NON-ENGLISH ]
SHE WAS REALLY SCARED, IN
HYSTERICS, TATYANA SAYS, SHE
CRIED, "GRAND MA, THE HOUSE WAS
HIT.
IT'S ON FIRE."
SHE TOLD ME, "MY MOTHER'S
UNCONSCIOUS UNDER THE RUBBLE."
HOW IS IT POSSIBLE WE DO THIS TO
EACH OTHER, HE ASKS.
I UNDERSTAND THIS ROCKET DIDN'T
TARGET THIS PLACE BUT HOW IS IT
POSSIBLE TO SHELL PEACEFUL
PEOPLE?
AND PEACEFUL PEOPLE, IN FACT
THREE PEOPLE WERE KILLED IN
THESE STRIKES.
TWO IN THE EASTERN CITY OF
KHARKIV AND ONE IN THE DONETSK
REGION.
AND OF COURSE THESE STRIKES,
THIS IS THE TENTH ROUND OF THESE
MASSIVE NATIONWIDE STRIKES
CONDUCTED BY THE RUSSIANS.
AND OF COURSE THEY DID IN SOME
INSTANCES GET MISSILES THROUGH.
IN THE CITY OF KHARKIV FOUR
MISSILES HIT WHAT'S BEING
DESCRIBED AS CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND WE GOT A STATEMENT JUST A
LITTLE WHILE AGO, WOLF, FROM THE
HEAD OF THE POWER COMPANY
PUTTING A SOMEWHAT DARKER TURN
TO THIS DAY WHEN MANY UKRAINIAN
OFFICIALS WERE HAPPY WITH THE
AMOUNT OF MISSILES THAT WERE
INTERCEPTED.
THE HEAD OF THE POWER COMPANY
SAID THAT THERE HAS BEEN
SIGNIFICANT DAMAGE TO THE
POWER-GENERATING SYSTEM IN
UKRAINE, AND HE SAID THE COMPANY
IS HAVING DIFFICULTY PROVIDING
ELECTRICITY -- TO RESTORING
ELECTRICITY TO PARTS OF KHARKIV,
KYIV, ODESA, MYKOLAIV, KHERSON
AND LVIV.
THAT'S BASICALLY ALL THE MAJOR
CITIES IN UKRAINE.
SO THEY MAY BE TAKING SOME
COMFORT, UKRAINIAN OFFICIALS,
FROM THE FACT THEY WERE ABLE TO
INTERCEPT 54 OUT OF THE 69
MISSILES FIRED TODAY IN ADDITION
TO 11 DRONES, BUT CLEARLY
SIGNIFICANT DAMAGE HAS BEEN
WREAKED UPON THE ALREADY
BATTERED ELECTRICAL SYSTEM HERE
IN UKRAINE.
WOLF?
>> AND IT'S COLD OVER THERE IN
WINTER.
AWFUL SITUATION.
BEN WEDEMAN, THANK YOU VERY,
VERY MUCH.
STAY SAFE OVER THERE.
LET'S GET SOME MORE ON WHAT'S
GOING ON.
JOINING US NOW, CNN MILITARY
ANALYST, RETIRED GENERAL WESLEY
CLARK.
THE FORMER NATO SUPREME ALLIED
COMMANDER.
ALSO WITH US, SENIOR CONTRIBUTOR
ON RUSSIAN AFFAIRS JILL DOHERTY.
GENERAL CLARK, THIS IS ONE OF
THE BIGGEST MISSILE ATTACKS OF
THE WAR BY THE RUSSIANS,
TARGETING AS WE HEARD ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
WHAT IS RUSSIA TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH AT THIS STAGE OF THE
WAR BY GOING AFTER THESE
CIVILIAN TARGETS?
>> WELL, I THINK THREE THINGS.
NUMBER ONE IS TO KEEP THE
UKRAINIAN GOVERNMENT AND PEOPLE
IN A STATE OF DISCOMFORT, TO
POUND THEM, TO SHOW THEM THAT
RUSSIA'S STILL THERE WHILE THEIR
GROUND FORCES ARE IN A STRATEGIC
DEFENSIVE POSTURE.
I THINK NUMBER TWO, THEY BELIEVE
IF THEY CAN KNOCK OUT THE ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE IT WILL KEEP
UKRAINE FROM REBUILDING ITS
MILITARY PRODUCTION FACILITIES
AND MAKE IT MUCH HARDER FOR
UKRAINE TO BE PREPARED FOR THE
NEXT RUSSIAN ONSLAUGHT.
AND THREE, I THINK IT SHOWS TO
THE WEST THE POWERFUL RUSSIAN
ATTACK, THE FACT THAT THEY'RE
RELENTLESS AND IT'S PART OF
TRYING TO DISCOURAGE THE WEST
FROM SUPPORTING UKRAINE AND
MAKING PEOPLE IN THE WEST SAY
OH, IT'S HOPELESS, IT'S A
NEVERENDING WAR, WE HAVE TO GET
A CEASE-FIRE, BA, BA, BA.
SO IT'S ALL PART OF AN
INTEGRATED RUSSIAN PLAN.
>> JILL, UKRAINE'S INTELLIGENCE
CHIEF NOW SAYS THIS WAR IS AT
WHAT HE CALLS A STALEMATE, WITH
NEITHER SIDE CAPABLE OF MAKING
SUBSTANTIAL GAINS.
WHAT'S THE MOOD INSIDE RUSSIA
RIGHT NOW AS THIS FIGHTINGING
DRAGS ON?
>> WELL, I THINK, YOU KNOW, FOR
THE PEOPLE OF RUSSIA SOMETIMES
IT'S VERY HARD TO SAY WHAT THEIR
MOOD IS.
SOME OF THEM SUPPORT IT.
OBVIOUSLY, A LOT OF THEM DO NOT.
BUT I THINK IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT
THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT IS DOING,
AND THIS IS -- I DEFINITELY
AGREE WITH THE GENERAL.
YOU KNOW, THIS IS A TIME IN THAT
REGION.
IT'S AS YOU SAID COLD.
THESE HOLIDAYS, THE NEW YEAR'S
HOLIDAY, WHICH IS JUST UPON US,
IS REALLY ONE OF THE BIGGEST
HOLIDAYS OF THE YEAR.
AND TO KEEP POUNDING UKRAINIANS,
REMOVE ANY TYPE OF HOPE THAT
THIS IS EVER GOING TO END, AND
THEN ALSO TODAY WE HAD
STATEMENTS BY THE FOREIGN
MINISTER AND THE SPOKESPERSON
FOR THE FOREIGN MINISTRY SAYING
ANY IDEA THAT WE ARE GOING TO
AGREE TO THE PEACE SETTLEMENT
THAT ZELENSKYY HAS PROPOSED,
FORGET IT, IT IS DELUSIONAL.
AND SO I THINK WHAT THEY'RE
TRYING TO DO IS EXACTLY, PUT UP
A FRONT AND SAY THIS IS NEVER
GOING TO END.
AND IT'S A MESSAGE BOTH TO
UKRAINIANS AND I THINK TO THE
RUSSIAN PEOPLE TOO BUT ALSO TO
THE WEST, DON'T EVEN THINK THAT
THIS IS GOING TO END, AND YOU
WILL HAVE TO KEEP SUPPORTING
THEM.
I TOTALLY AGREE THAT THIS IS A
VERY ORGANIZED APPROACH AT THIS
POINT.
>> GENERAL CLARK, DO YOU SEE
ANYTHING BREAKING THE STALEMATE
RIGHT NOW, POTENTIALLY THE
ARRIVAL OF EVEN MORE U.S. AND
OTHER WEAPONS, WESTERN WEAPONS?
>> I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE
DIFFICULT TO BREAK OUT OF THE --
AND BREAK THROUGH THE RUSSIAN
DEFENSES THAT ARE THERE WITHOUT
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE U.S. MILITARY
ASSISTANCE.
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING THAT
THE UKRAINIANS NEED IS
LONG-RANGE LOITERING MUNITIONS,
SOMETHING SIMILAR TO THE IRANIAN
DRONES.
THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO GO BACK
BEYOND THE HIMARS RANGE AND GO
AFTER THE RUSSIAN SUPPLY DEPOTS
AND COMMAND POSTS THAT HAVE BEEN
MOVED OUT OF RANGE.
AND THEY NEED THE INTELLIGENCE
TO GO AFTER THE IMPROVED RUSSIAN
DEFENSES.
AND I HEAR SOME MILITARY
ADVISERS SAYING YOU KNOW, THE
UKRAINIANS HAVE TO UNDERSTAND
THEY CAN'T BEAT THE RUSSIANS ARE
ARTILLERY, BA, BA, BA, YOU CAN'T
MATCH THEM TWO FOR TWO.
THAT MAY BE WHAT WE SAY BECAUSE
WE DON'T HAVE THAT ARTILLERY.
BUT THIS WAR IS RAPIDLY EVOLVING
INTO A WORLD WAR I KIND OF
TRENCH WARFARE WHERE THE
RUSSIANS ARE REALLY EMPLACING
THEIR POSITIONS IN DONBAS AND IT
IS GOING TO TAKE A MASSIVE FIRE
SUPPORT, NOT NECESSARILY
ARTILLERY, COULD BE AIRCRAFT,
BUT WE'RE NOT GIVING THEM THE
AIRCRAFT